recently the FCC took another swing at
what's loosely called net neutrality
I guess I'd count myself among those
whom not sure it's an earth-shattering
deal shouldn't come as that much of a
surprise that a chairman of the FCC is a
former head of the cable television
Association and the wireless
associations is not doing anything
that's going to bring anything down I
guess what's most notable about the the
rules is they're coming down again is
they're applying to wireless that had
been left off the table by rules that
were in place from 2010 to 2014 but I
suspect that most Internet service
providers can live within these rules
the long term question is going to be to
what extent to Internet service
providers feel they need to earn money
through something other than
cash-and-carry delivery of what we think
of as generic broadband you know we're
just gonna give you good bandwidth
you're gonna pay for it have fun out
there is the Internet service provider
of the traditional vein if they're
wanting to cut a bunch of what you might
think it was more interesting deals
we'll wait a minute maybe we'll charge
more for one particular provider like
Google to have to reach our eyeballs of
our subscribers and you know Google can
pay for that and maybe this is the ideal
case for this kind of argument that net
neutrality doesn't allow maybe it'll
even turn out that we can offer free
internet access to people they'll pay
nothing per month because it'll get paid
for subsidized on the other side as the
googles of the world pay to beat a path
to the door of our subscribers that
might be a good idea the thing is that
the number of outs that involve some
form of differential pricing of being
very canny about whose bits are coming
from where and going to where and
whether those will be treated
differently or charged differently more
frequently I think would not result in
free internet for consumers but in added
revenue for
company that simply goes back to the
shareholders and really is reflecting
the fact that there isn't a lot of
competition in America today for the
provision of broadband if you live in a
house and you want a fast internet
connection you don't have a ton of
choices in many places you only have one
choice for who you're gonna use and at
that point they don't have the same
incentives that a competitive
marketplace would give and that's one
reason why something like net neutrality
makes a lot of sense it's been
interesting to see that around the world
there's been a laboratory for different
regulatory and technical regimes for
implementation of Internet access in a
place like the United Kingdom they don't
talk much about net neutrality because
they have a regime where British Telecom
the legacy government affiliated
telephony provider is a wholesaler and
then virgin broadband and others can
resell it and that means that if one
started to get too canny no Google for
you because Google refused to pay us
their subscribers would leave and use a
different ISP even though it's all going
over the same pipe you might not need
net neutrality the way that you see it
shaping up in America where there isn't
that open access mandate the third
category to keep an eye out for over the
years is municipal broadband should it
be that just like governments provide
roads and fill or don't fill potholes in
them that municipalities might choose to
offer fibre to each home you pay them a
flat fee and that's the end of the story
one of the interesting artifacts of the
recent FCC decision is actually
overturning state level legislative bans
on municipal broadband provision that
had been enacted in part at the behest
of existing Internet service providers
that would prefer not to compete with
the government to provide Internet
access and we will see now maybe a
couple cities in which the
municipalities will have a chance to
offer it as well and I'm curious to see
where that leads
you